President Trump launched his bid for a
second term by painting a scary picture
of America's future if he's not reelect
'add the president rallied with
thousands of supporters in Orlando to
officially start the campaign while he
faced turmoil back in Washington
his 75 minute address last night brought
up very familiar themes he accused his
critics of on American conduct that's a
quote lashed out at the press and
claimed that Democrats quote want to
destroy our country he also said destroy
all of you referring to his voters we
Shashank has been traveling with the
president she's in Miami we Joe what
else did he have to say Tony he had a
lot to say he build this rally as
historic and the hottest ticket ever but
it was actually just a collection of his
greatest hits he revisited old rivalries
aired familiar grievances and renewed
those longstanding promises he has made
since his campaign in 2016 because in
many ways it never ended tonight I stand
before you to officially launch my
campaign for a second term
President Trump and his supporters
agreed on an updated campaign slogan
Keep America great if I lose
people are gonna say what a mistake that
was but we're not gonna lose so it's not
gonna matter but he did not offer a new
agenda to go with it instead the
president painted a dire picture of what
will happen if he loses our radical
Democratic owners are driven by hatred
prejudice and rage mr. Trump only
mentioned two of those opponents by name
Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders though he
focused on his former rival Hillary
Clinton crooked Hillary said if I win
are you gonna support me it did amazing
that it worked the other way around
right and he stuck to the familiar
talking points but he's relied on since
his unlikely first run four years ago
when Mexico sends its people they're not
sending their best our immigration laws
are a disgrace even though he's found
those problems hard to solve in
Washington the swap is fighting back so
viciously but to his loyal base who
waited four days to get into the rally
the stump speech isn't the point no
matter what the polls say or what you
know the news says we love them when we
got his back even though President Trump
did not do a deep dive into the current
Democratic field the candidate certainly
responded to him including Bernie
Sanders who described watching the
speech as quote an unpleasant experience
Anthony we just thank you